When was the last time
you walked down the street
in a city with new buildings?
I want to talk to you about the problem
that we all know exists
in our towns and cities.
We're increasingly surrounded
by characterless buildings.
I believe we're living through
an epidemic of boringness.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
With a few exceptions,
we all know that new buildings
will be dead and monotonous.
Everywhere is the same.
Dull, flat, straight, shiny.
Inhuman.
They're what my daughter
calls "meh" buildings.
These buildings justify themselves
as being functional.
I’m a designer of buildings,
and I’ve been told so many times
that form should follow function.
Meaning if I work out mechanically
how a building goes together well,
the outcome will somehow
inevitably look good.
This mantra, form follows function,
is a century old.
And it sounds good, doesn't it?
Who can argue with that?
Surely any extra detail is just silly,
unnecessary decoration.
I want to talk about the function
that's crucial
that I believe is missing.
The function of emotion.
And when I say emotion,
I mean the ability of buildings
to mean something to us.
To lift our spirits, to connect us.
Buildings affect us.
We walk around them, we look up at them.
And for most of us,
for the vast majority of the time,
they just leave us feeling indifferent.
So if I took all of us to a city and said,
"Which bit would you like to go to?
Would you like to go to the old bit
or the new bit?"
(Laughter)
You've given me my answer already.
We all know instinctively,
the majority are going
to pick the old bit.
Why?
Because we all know the new bit
will be characterless and boring.
So where did all the lumps
and bumps on buildings go?
The shadows, the textures,
the three-dimensionality,
the high points of light.
How did it all become so two dimensional,
so simplistic and devoid of character?
Well, it turns out,
I'm not the only one who's alarmed
by what's happening
in our towns and cities.
There's research showing
that these buildings
aren't just simplistic and monotonous.
They're harming us.
They're bad for our mental health,
causing stress in our brains
as we walk around them.
They're bad for our physical health,
making us take longer to recover
from illness inside them.
And they're also bad for societal health,
increasing the likelihood of crime
and anti-social behavior.
But this gets most sinister
when we step back
and think about the climate crisis
unfolding around us.
Immense emphasis has been placed
on the impact of cars and aviation.
And in this 2019 study,
aviation was responsible for 2.1 percent
of greenhouse gas emissions.
But the crazy elephant in the room
is that the construction
industry as a whole
is responsible for a whopping 38 percent.
And in America every year,
a billion square foot of buildings
are destroyed and rebuilt.
That’s the equivalent of half
of Washington, DC being deconstructed
just to be reconstructed.
And this isn't just in the US.
This is global.
In the UK, we demolish
50,000 buildings a year.
The average age of a commercial building
in the UK is 40 years.
So that means if I had been born
as a commercial building,
I would have been killed 12 years ago.
(Laughter)
It's quite straightforward.
When people don't love --
and I'm using the word love --
love buildings,
they're more likely to demolish them.
I feel those two dots
haven't been connected together.
But when you make a building,
one of the most expensive things
you can possibly do,
there are understandably huge
pressures of cost of time,
of politics and egos
and regulations and the status quo.
These forces of soullessness are immense.
And change is scary for everybody,
myself included.
But I'm convinced that emotion
is the crucial function
that's been forgotten.
There are, however,
a tiny handful of people
who do understand
and are trying to address this.
Here's a few of them.
In France,
Sou Fujimoto has designed this
amazingly textured apartment building.
In Burkina Faso,
Francis Kéré has made
this soulful health center.
In Lebanon,
Lina Ghotmeh Architecture
has been using splendidly thick walls
to make characterful housing.
And in the UK,
ACME Studio have been bringing
personality and detail
to city center buildings.
I thought I'd now show you a few examples
of ways my own studio
has been trying to address this too.
In Cape Town,
there was a huge century-old
disused grain silo
that was once used for storing maize
from throughout South Africa
that was at significant risk
of being demolished.
We proposed to not knock it down,
but instead turned it into Africa's
first major institution
for contemporary African artists.
(Applause)
You haven't seen it yet.
(Laughter)
We took one of the original grain --
You might get disappointed now.
(Laughter)
We took one of the original grains of corn
that had been stored
in the original building.
And we cut it out
of the heart of that building.
And around that put 80 galleries.
And most of our work was about restoring
and reinvigorating a historical structure.
But central part of our vision
was using our limited budget
to create the most
compelling heart possible
with those gigantic tubes.
(Applause)
And the key thing was
how we could make people
not just stand at the outside
and admire a structure,
but how we could pull them into the inside
where curiosity would then
do the rest of the work.
And you enter under the grain hoppers
where the grain used to drop
onto the conveyor belts.
And we loved that by cutting
through the original, historic,
extraordinary structure,
we could expose and share
the building's idiosyncrasies.
And like these nooks and crannies,
they help to give
the project its soulfulness.
And on the top is a sculpture garden
with a glass floor.
And if you see those babies
on the glass just there,
this is their view.
The finished museum is raw,
it's rough, but it's true.
And it was an honor to bring
this historic structure back into life.
In Singapore,
we searched for solutions
for why would people be excited
to learn in universities anymore?
In this new digital era
where you can do
virtually everything online,
and you can even get a PhD
lying in bed, I've heard,
why do we need university
buildings anymore?
Well, we believe they're where you come
together to have ideas,
to meet your future business partner
or the person you're going to set up
a not-for-profit with.
Yet this has been the typical experience.
Polystyrene ceiling tiles,
no natural daylight,
the least inspiring place to meet people.
So to counter that,
we made a corridor-less
university building
where the students can all see each other.
A building which has no front
and has no back.
And it's not one building,
it's actually 12 buildings.
Our goal was to invent a new kind
of tropical architecture
that used the minimum possible energy,
where you learn in corner-less classrooms.
Where those professors
and teachers work with you
rather than dictating to you.
Where people can be inspired by learning
but encouraged to linger.
And it's open 24 hours.
And when I was last in Singapore,
I had jet lag and it was
two o'clock in the morning.
And so I went along
and there were students there
just quietly working and connecting.
In Yorkshire, in the UK,
we had the chance to humanize
a treatment building
at one of the UK's largest
cancer hospitals.
So when you think of the worst building
environments you've ever been to,
surely hospitals
are at the top of that list.
They're some of the most stress
and fear-inducing places
you can possibly be in.
So we set ourselves the mission
to make a non-clinical building
where you could feel vulnerable.
And cry and feel protected
and come together as a community.
But our site was on the last bit
of greenery at the hospital.
And we didn't want to be the ones
who dropped a big box
and wiped out all that greenery.
So we wondered instead,
could we amplify the greenery
that we knew could help with healing?
So just like those dinosaur models
made from plywood that slot together,
we slotted together giant plywood
to make three structures
to hold up three major gardens
and make a garden building.
This building has 17,000 plants,
23,000 bulbs,
and actually a 436 percent
biodiversity increase on that site.
(Applause)
Our goal was to really make somewhere
where people could come together
and where by focusing
on the emotion of the users
to really try to make
an architecture of hope.
Finally, in Shanghai,
we had the chance
that's typical of our time.
The challenge of bigness.
To make a three and a half million
square-foot site,
a building project on a site
that was 480 meters long.
Where typically
this is what would be built.
The site was so big
that the Empire State Building
could fit on it lying sideways.
So to make this cost efficient,
structurally effective,
we needed 1,000 columns on a grid,
so we decided to not just decorate boxes,
but to let the columns be our heroes
and to connect with the park to one side
and the art district on the other side
and try to bring them together into one.
The finished project is called
“A Thousand Trees.”
(Applause)
Every one of those columns
has a Chinese mountain tree,
semi-mature mountain tree on top.
And nourishment and drainage
and lighting and moisture,
and because every column
is the best place to put a heavy load.
And it has hundreds of outdoor terraces
and it has shading
and it has, we hope,
the necessary complexity
to create the human engagement
in a project at such a scale.
We also worked with local artists
to embed their work into our vision,
to really make a collaborative
project together.
And that carries through
all the way to the inside.
And this project opened
at the end of last year,
the first half of it.
And we have 100,000
people going to it every day.
And it wasn't just about trees and plants,
but even structural columns
were our friends
to humanize the project at such a scale.
So I'm not saying
that there's any one language or approach
to deal with this epidemic of boring.
Just like in nature,
we've learned the vast
importance of biodiversity,
we now desperately need
architectural diversity.
(Applause)
My goal is to try to help trigger
a global humanizing movement
that no longer tolerates
soulless, inhuman places.
What if our buildings inspired us
to want to adapt and adjust
and repair them?
We can't keep knocking down
the buildings around us all the time.
Let’s stop building 40-year buildings,
and let's build a 1,000-year buildings.
Please join me.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)